hmm
thank you for joining today my name is
joseph pearson
and i'm happy to present a solution for
exploring deeply curated single cell
transcriptomic data
to accelerate biomarker research
the products shown here are intended for
molecular biology applications
these products are not intended for the
diagnosis prevention
or treatment of a disease
so omixot's goal is to accelerate
advances in biomarker and target
discovery
by helping scientists quickly explore
curated data sets
to answer questions about disease
indications and biomarkers
and to support deeper analyses across
data sets
so scientists can confirm hypotheses
omixos omixoff does this by curating
huge collections of disease relevant
omics data
currently at 580 000 samples
over 30 databases and over 7000 projects
providing access to these data through
software
and direct data access such as apis and
text dumps
and this means that scientists don't
have to spend valuable time
searching for processing and curating
data sets
only to find that the data set wasn't as
relevant as you thought
you can get right to the data
exploration
scientists can explore our huge
repository to discover
data sets relevant to their research
discover where their genes have
expressed interest are expressed across
normal and disease samples they can also
explore
mutation copy number gene dependency
and other multi-ohmic data and discover
where their genes are differentially
expressed and then
use this information and upload directly
into ipa
to compare against other curated data
sets to expand your search
now with omixof's single cell lands we
extend
these capabilities to the single cell
resolution
you can explore the broad collection of
data in oncoland and diseaseland
discovering curated datasets relevant to
your research
with over 580 000 samples to identify
relevant tissues indications and
biomarkers
and then knife deeper and refine your
hypotheses by
exploring our collection of deeply
curated single cell projects
use our controlled vocabularies and
extensive curated metadata
to find the most relevant data sets
explore hundreds of manually curated
cell types from these projects
and visualize expression data within and
across projects to clearly see
exactly where your genes are expressed
our in-depth curation process and data
analysis pipelines
allow scientists to ask in-depth
questions harnessing the power
of deeply curated metadata and data to
get answers
if you have an indication or a tissue or
even a cell type of interest
you can use the detailed metadata to
group and filter projects
to find data sets that will find that
will provide the answers you need
then explore the precomputed comparisons
to quickly find
differentially expressed genes for a
curated cell type
and then validate these genes directly
at the cell level
overlaying expression on the
pre-computed dimension reduction plots
or if you have candidate biomarkers
and you want to confirm exactly where
they're expressed
you can quickly visualize gene
expression across data sets
or within data sets grouped on any
curated metadata
identify curated cell clusters where
your gene of interest
is specifically upregulated or down
regulated
to understand its enrichment and
specificity and then of course
confirm this at the cell level
now most importantly our curated single
cell data sets
include detailed manual cell cluster
curation
with specific cell types from our
controlled vocabularies
this enables the user to start by
exploring the breadth of disease
coverage
within disease land and uncle land
to identify tissues and diseases and
experiments expressing
genes of interest then you can dive
deeper
into the specific cell types for those
tissues within single cell lands
to understand exactly which cells
express these genes
and this is just a small snapshot of the
depth of manual curation
of the cell types our curators have
identified
as with all omisoftlands our curation
priorities
are driven by our users
throughout 2021 we will continue to
rapidly add
new deeply curated projects focusing
on therapeutic areas like oncology
neurology gastroenterology dermatology
pulmonology and more
the key guiding principle of the single
cell land design
is cross project exploration which
allows scientists
to group filter and explore data across
studies this requires that our
curation process is consistent with
detailed controlled vocabularies
like what we use in diseaseland and
ankle9 collections
also use a consistent set of pipelines
to re-analyze data from
the raw files through cluster generation
and identification
and finally our framework stores the
metadata in a logical hierarchy
allowing scientists to dynamically
filter and group at any
meta data level from the project level
down to the cell cluster
and this allows scientists to explore
data within
individual curated projects or merge the
data and explore across projects
our single cell curation process is
really an extension of the way that we
curate data for oncoland
and diseaseland this is an intensive
process
but it's essential for in-depth and
confident data analysis
and interpretation starting with
data set requests from our users our
curators check that their
requested data are available compatible
with the platform
and of course that the publication
provides enough
information and enough detail to
interpret the data
our bioinformaticians then retrieve the
data
and confirm that the data are available
and that the data submission
has all the samples it's complete
along with the barcodes and the umi
parsing information
next our curators curate the metadata
from the data submission
and publication extracting the project
technical sample and clinical metadata
applying our controlled vocabularies and
curation cleanup standards
our curators also identify expected
results from the paper
such as clustering expected cell types
and key difference the expressed marker
genes
meanwhile our bioinformaticians align
and quantify the data
on a consistent set of pipelines
performing
post-processing qc checks on the data
then using guidance from the curator's
information
they perform dimension reduction
analysis and clustering analysis
to define the cell clusters that best
match
the expected cell types for the project
they also run
comparisons between the clusters to
identify the differentially expressed
genes
the markers for these clusters
and finally our curators use this
information from the bioinformaticians
to manually inspect the clusters and the
overexpressed genes
and manually curate each individual
cluster
for the curated cell type
all of the curated data and metadata can
be directly explored because they are
organized hierarchically
filter and group the data at any
metadata at the project level
biological sample level or even the
curated cell cluster level and use this
to focus down on the cell level
expression
and differential expression analysis
that is relevant to your research
and with this single cell land framework
we make it easy to query the data
and the metadata to answer your
biomarker questions to complement your
discoveries within diseaseland
and oncoland it's simple to get an
overview of all of the available content
within the single cell lens with our
distribution views
exploring the data by research focus
tissue
disease cell type and more the curated
project
sample and cluster metadata should be
used to slice and dice the data
to narrow down your search for relevant
data sets
you can filter on any metadata
regroup the data in the plot
and then explore the curated details to
know that you've found
the relevant data for your research
or you can dive right into the project
details
you can visualize the cell level details
with dimension reduction plots
filtering and labeling on any of the
extensive metadata
like cell type tissue disease
treatment status age and so forth
compare similar projects to identify
those with the samples
and the cell types relevant to your
research
with a carefully curated metadata you
can also plot
the cell composition of each cluster
grouped on sample id or any other
metadata
you're interested in so you can look for
the changes in cell prevalence and
composition
within samples or groups of samples and
this is really powerful for looking at
shifts in curated cell populations
between samples
like between normal indices
or before and after treatment
to look for those changes in cell
populations
now because our bioinformaticians
compute full differential expression
results between
curated clusters you can explore all of
these data directly
use our pre-computed comparisons between
clusters
along with the curated metadata to
quickly identify genes that were
up or down regulated in your cluster of
interest
compare these comparisons across
projects with similar cell types
to confirm gene markers and signatures
that mark your
cells of interest or contrast similar
curated cell clusters within a project
to identify subtle differences that
might differentiate disease versus
normal
and so forth
you can see the distribution of gene
expression within
and across cell clusters and projects by
just searching for a gene
group and filter the cell clusters on
any of the metadata to see the
similarities and differences of
expression across
projects because of the consistent
curation
you can be confident about the labels in
the grouping
and so you can see where genes like egfr
are expressed
across multiple tissues across multiple
projects
and within specific curated cell types
you could also search for any gene and
quickly see where your gene was
upregulated or down regulated within the
precomputed
statistical comparisons and this is
really great for
confirming details of marker genes you
might have found in the disease study
and diseaseland or oncoland
after you've found candidate biomarkers
for disease
treatment etc within the differential
expression bubble plot
identify the specific cell clusters
where your gene
is differentially expressed helping you
refine your hypotheses
and then explore the cell level details
by
overlaying your gene of interests
expression across
the dimension reduction plots and scroll
through and explore
and confirm the expression in cell types
you knew maybe discover expression in
cell types that you didn't expect
use this to confirm the specificity of
expression within a tissue
or even between similar cell clusters
with the same curated cell type to look
for differences
and you can quickly flip between the
expression
and the deep curation of metadata on any
metadata level
to understand exactly where your gene is
being
expressed
you can search multiple genes to look
for similarities and differences in
expression
select the most specific markers and
identify signatures that are upregulated
in specific cell clusters
so you can search for multiple genes and
look for the patterns of expression
and specificity across these genes to
look for those specific
markers and those consistent signatures
and confirm those signatures
with differential expression
looking for patterns of up and down
regulation
that mark the specific cell types and
then use this information back in
diseaseland or alkaline
to identify indications that correspond
to these expression patterns
to accelerate your discovery
and the single cell lands should really
be thought of the data hub
the starting place for deeply curated
data
the whole design of the framework is to
enable you to discover
important data sets using omixoff's deep
curation
and analysis pipeline
with the staging of the data within the
server to use the framework to explore
the data
with the summary visualizations to to
identify
the data sets and the biomarkers that
are relevant and then export the full
results
into omixoff studio analysis projects
for deeper analysis
or you can export selected genes
of interest and the metadata columns for
export within
h5ad format the open standard for
interco
compatibility for example to display in
the salvaging browser
or for analysis and parsing in other
popular open source packages
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your time